التحايل على الموت والعيش الى الابد فكره
تسحر عقول البشر وسعى كثيرون الى الوصول
اليها وتحقيقها لكن لو قلت لكم ان هناك
مخلوقا خالدا يعيش على كوكب الارض هل
تصدقون هذا الكائن هو قنديل البحر وبالضبط
من فصيلته
ليس فقط لا يموت بل يعيش شابا طوال حياته
والسبب انه قادر على تجديد خلاياه بشكل
متكرر ولذا يعود الى مرحله الشباب دوما
ولا تكون لديه مرحله شيخوخه تنتهي بالموت
كسائر المخلوقات على هذه الارض هذا
المخلوق العجيب الذي لا يتجاوز قطره
الخمسه مليمترات يتكاثر بشكل لا جنسي دون
الحاجه الى وجود ذكر وانثى ويعيش في
المياه الاستوائيه الدافئه ومع انه لا
يموت الا ان ذلك قد يحدث عن طريق مؤثر
خارجي كافتراسه من قبل مخلوق اخر او خروجه
من مياه البحر